sabine weiss est il exact que vous avez
un jour fait des photos pour avoir un
bifteck quand vous arrivez à paris et
que vous aviez décidé
d'être photographe professionnel et que
parce qu'il fallait la gagner sa vie de
temps en temps vous photographiez l'état
l'âge du du marchande du bifteck oui oh
que oui c'est exact mais en fait il faut
dire que j'étais déjà photographe depuis
quand je faisais ça j'avais déjà
je pas 3 au 7 ou 8 ans de métier mais
c'était le début de la photographie à
paris où je ne connaissais personne
n'avait aucune relation ni dans la
presse ni rien donc il fallait débuter
fallait faire des choses et puis puis 7
elle s'était aussi amusant d'ailleurs
les étalages de boucher avec lesquels je
faisais des échanges étaient beaucoup
plus beau que maintenant ils demandent
leur label bodian temps voyait les les
feux qui étaient accrochés ils mettaient
des fleurs dessus des fleurs de ré en
fait cet été décorés mais yb était aussi
des tabliers à la sur la viande en fin
et j'ai c'est vrai que je proposais de
un échange vous avez commencé à
photographier dès l'âge de 12 ans vous
êtes d'origine suisse qu'est-ce qu'est
ce qui fait que il vous y restez chez
vous et vous êtes tout à l'heure on a
parlé de l'arpenteur vous êtes
l'humaniste et vous faites partie de
cette de deux sets de 7 avant lui le
côté humaniste je suis photographe oui
oui oui parce que j'ai fait des fautes
aux yeux que vous traitez vous dite
humaniste oui mais enfin j'avais c'était
vraiment mon métier est ce que
j'avais fait un apprentissage et j'avais
vraiment un bagage solide mentalité
calviniste 1res de l'éducation quoi oui
ça plane comme tu as un aperçu de vos
oeuvres
qui sont présentés à la maison
européenne de la photographie c'est
jusqu'en janvier 2009
on va y voir ben voilà un jeune mineur
sa date de 50 ou après on va y voir une
petite danseuse gitane puis la sculpture
cheval et une femme un homme dans le
brouillard des enfants joint au cheval
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont été vos premières
préoccupations quand vous êtes devenu
photographe professionnel parce que
c'est ce métier qui vous passionnait que
vous aviez envie de faire
écouter jeu comme je vous le disais j'ai
fait un apprentissage donc je pouvais
faire de tout donc dès le début ce nas
chez boissonnat qui était une maison en
suisse qui avait qui fait est déjà en
jeu c'était en 1942 et la maison fêtait
ses 80 ans c'est à dire que c'était vrai
mandat d une dynastie de photographes et
il y avait même encore un appareil 50 60
en bois pour prendre des photos on s'en
servait plus mais enfin il y avait un
matériel comme ça très curieux dans ce
matériel techniquement est ce que vous
êtes passés au numérique ou est ce que
j'adore le numérique que c'est bien lui
mairie je vais vraiment je recommande à
tout le monde ça fait des photos de
facilement ça met au point sa fin le
temps de pause c'est léger moi qui
prends un peu de d'âge pas beaucoup mais
un petit peu donc je suis contente
d'avoir des appareils plus légers vous
vous êtes entré
l agence rapho en 1952 grâce à doisneau
on a vu votre travail et on voit bien la
sensibilité de votre travail
en même temps vous avez aussi travaillé
pour d'autres choses vous avez fait de
la photo des portraits de la photo de
commandes de la pub alors à part le
portrait portrait de cobb commandes j'ai
tout fait
tout fait sans vergogne sans vergogne
j'ai fait tout et
j'ai puis jamais bien c'était un défi
chaque fois différent de se plonger
dedans
dans des appareils de format très très
différent ça allait jusqu'au 25 du 24 36
j'ai fait
parler de films de photographes de
plateau j'en ai fait aussi j'ai fait
j'ai fait de la mort galata tous et
notamment une fois vous avez voulu
photographier un mort qui n'était pas
mort si je maman qui était pas mort
ça c'est nouveau c'est peut-être la
prochaine photo lorsque le le moment
dans la chambre ou de photographier la
la personne se lève en dit attendez
c'est pas mon bon profil c'était une
blague a pas du tout ah non mais moi ça
parce que c'est vrai du tout raconté moi
parce que ça m'a fait rire
tout rond b téléphone à soir on veut que
j'aime photographier une dame qui était
morte extraordinaire je pisse discute la
discussion prend trop de temps je dis
bon finalement je viens je viens et je
vais de nuit avenue foch vers la
photographie de cette dame ordre et
quand j'arrive le on me dit on va vous
présenter over enfin c'était somptueux
les lustres était drapé de voile noir
enfin je crois même que la chaise sur
laquelle je me suis assise et et revers
de nice mais enfin c'est peut-être pas
mal à cela mais je pense que tu aimerais
et donc le veuf arrive et me prend la
main avec plaisir et me dit mais ma
petite dame comme c'est gentil d'être
venu bon il me dit entrez entrez vous
allez bien prendre quelque chose et il
me fait rentrer dans sa salle de bain et
il y avait beaucoup de monde qui étaient
là et dans la baignoire il y avait les
blocs de glace comme on faisait à
l'époque c'était vide et les gros blocs
de glace donc on fait l'amour quoi est
il y avait le champagne est alors bon je
bois le champagne avec tout le monde
après je je reprends mon air de
circonstance je dis je vais aller
travailler et on y va tous ensemble ils
tout le monde tout le monde arrive dans
la chambre de la morte il ment ce
merveilleux un lit à baldaquin comme on
peut pas s'imaginer il se passe quoi ce
mois un orbe et c'était incroyable bon
je commence à m 2 de l'éclairage y avait
des la copine de dûmes du veuf qui qu'il
trouvait que c'était embêtant de nouveau
les spots les sunlights de lui il était
content il s'est dit c'est comme au
cinéma et tout ça il veille à beaucoup
d'épisodes parce qu'il vient mais le
dernier le dernier la chute la chute la
chute de l'agout il y eut relie dit je
dis qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qu'il
attendait alors on a en a tiré les
hallebardes à cannes je me suis coincé
derrière lee pour prendre le bon profil
évidemment j'ai fait sauter tous les
fusibles et je me suis retrouvé coincé
derrière le lit avec la bande
évidemment
commenter vos photos femme dans le métro
7,7 en
1978 on s'arrête peut-être sur cette
photo est alors oui oui c'est une photo
il ya des personnes qui me me disais que
c'était honteux d'avoir photographié
cette femme si si malheureux si
désespérée mais je trouve que non parce
que c'est un témoignage et d'ailleurs
elle avait beaucoup sans doute frappé
yasmina reza qui dans le lycée livre qui
s'appelle look du hasard ra parle de
cette photo elle dit et il voit dans le
métro une femme d'avec son fichu et son
gros manteau et enfin elle décrit ses
mollets sais tu sais je sais ces gens
bande et son sac et tous dansent dans ce
livre je vous propose d'écouter robert
doisneau sur le plateau d' apostrophes
c'était le 8 juin 79 lors d'une émission
consacrée à la photographie c'est grâce
à lui que vous êtes entré donc
l agence rapho je vais faire simplement
une une remarque
dans votre travail vous êtes plus vous
dans la recherche de l'instant dans la
recherche d'une lumière filmé dans la
recherche de l'instant alors que
doisneau à accepter beaucoup la mise en
scène ce qui était pas votre cas en
écoute doisneau
chez moi je suis d'une humeur délicieuse
se peut pas rester à l'intérieur ça faut
que je transporte mais je suis pas ton
titre est loin alors si je vais à deux
pas de chez moi
j'ai un constat de la grèce des mythes
eux dont je fais partie alors là je fais
mon travail de photographe humaniste
qu'est ce qui nous intéressait la
réalité quotidienne oyonnax pas de
réalité pour moi il ya non je suis un
faux témoins ah bon je m'emmêle je
montre dans la vie la façade qui
m'arrange et jeudi c'est de la photo
donc cet indéniable qu'est-ce que vous
arrangerait ville le deuil de d'avoir un
monde de gens drôles
qui aime bien faire des blagues qui
guillaume boucher de métier que j'aime
bien avoir montré sa non les autres
facettes je les effaçais lâchement de
shenzhen
commentaires
et écouter cet émouvant de revoir robert
comme ça
nos points de vue étaient très très
différents et moi c'est un homme qui
était plein d'humour
moi j'ai pas du mot j'ai juste là sous
le regard la sensibilité peut-être mais
je l'aimé énormément il m'a beaucoup
apporté dans la vie puisque je les
rencontre et un jour aveugle et comme il
s'est penché sur mon travail pour voir
ce que je faisais et ça m'a ouvert les
portes de drapeaux et de vogue et puis
tout le reste un là il faut séparer
non mais ça c'est le boulot ça c'est le
métier qui m'a amené partout d'ailleurs
comment ton vos photos
une photo qu'on a quand même famille de
harkis ou des enfants qui se fabrique
des planches des planches à roulettes
qu'est ce qui fait votre humanisme
le fin fond de moi peut-être en face de
ce qu'est ce qui fait manquer life et
respect qu'on voit dans vos photos par
rapport aux sujets photographiés écoutez
je ne sais pas est ce que c'est bon
calvinisme j'ai un peu certainement je
ne sais pas c'est le peut-être
j'ai eu une vie heureuse très heureuse
peut-être que c'est ça aussi j'ai pas
eue j'ai eu l'heureuse mans très peu de
de malheur il ya des gens qui ont tout
le temps des maladies des malheurs des
morts j'ai eu beaucoup de chance dans la
vie j'ai eu à marie que jamais qu'ils
m'aimaient weiss oui à peintre qui mord
qui est mort et est donc
je pense que que jette j'étais libre
j'étais pas je m'en manquait
d'agressivité peut-être et sentimentale
on m'a dit aussi beaucoup vous étiez la
photographe l'a eu une portraitiste des
âmes des filiations les mères
les enfants
et puis on a dit aussi que vous
photographiez justement beaucoup
beaucoup les enfants je voudrais qu'on
vous regarde dans une séance de travail
c'était en 1965 oui et vous préparez eu
un enfant
à prendre dans ses mains une colombe
regardez ce que ça donne
moi je vois besoin de ce pas ce que ça
donne attends je te rends tu ta chemise
rue tu as ta chemise cutter
quelque 5 kg de bois c'est pour fermer
la peau
bon alors maintenant tu sais qu'on va
faire on va photo fait photographier
avec les toisons alors tu va le prendre
dans ta main à temps reste de bouger tes
données d'un bruit tu sais il est gros
pour centrer parfaitement port
alalalala on y arrivera bien
voilà
mais je crois qu'il n'est pas content
tiens regarde tu sais ce que tu vas
faire bien bien césar qui veulent
prendre bien avec moi oh mais tu t il
aime beaucoup les petits enfants
regardent le
regarde comme il à mes petits-enfants
vient rien je viens tu vas sentir
compris coeur tu parles tu vois deux
mois dès demain donne moi tes mains d'un
mathema tu vois rien
pauvres bêtes oui mais ce qu'est ce que
je trouve étonnant parce que je le vois
je photographie seul puisque photographe
puis je m'étais l'animal et jeu et on
voit qui est l'appareil est prêt pour
que j'aille photographier je
photographiais toujours son assistante
et c'est ça c'est à messam ça m'étonne
maintenant beaucoup je voudrais qu'on
regarde une dernière d'une dernière de
photos
c'est l'accordéoniste et puis on vient
de voir que reza se balade toujours avec
avec son appareil photo lui est ce que
vous vous êtes comme ces photographes
qui se balade toujours avec leur
appareil photo pour j pour saisir ce qui
pourrait se passer pas du tout moi ce
que ce que j'aime c'est que quand je
fais de la photo que je ne fasse que ça
je vais pas me balader balader je vais
pas acheter une une congestion bichat
sauf quand vous achetez un bifteck vous
y mettiez but ça après je vais acheter
plus vives texte est comme ça
non vous voyez demander quoi j'ai vu je
perds du fait de ces vous baladiez
toujours avec votre ami non pas du tout
pas du tout est-ce que vous avez un
objet avec vous écouter on m'a demandé
d'en apporter à mais j'ai oublié mais
finalement l'objet oui j'en ai un
attendez je vais le jeu le trouver c'est
un peu ça il a dit qu il a disparu non
c'est un personne de son nom c'est mon
petit porte-clefs cas philippe salle n a
ni photographe m'a donné un jour et il
l'avait fait marquer mon nom dessus
waouh et il est très utile je laime
beaucoup gelé depuis tellement d'années
qu'il a dû me me racheter un couteau et
me refaire m mais les extérieurs de mon
vrai couteau dessus et c'est la suisse
ne suis pas et je m'en sers tu fort est
souvent parce qu'il y avait des tas de
choses
[Musique]